KLAY THOMPSON COMING OFF THAT
THE BALL.
THEY'VE TRIED TO DO THAT EARLRL
PERIMETER.
LOONEY IS AN ADEPT DEFENDER OUT
THERE.
SMART, SCREEN WHERE
AL HORFORD IS BACK AND STEPH
CURRY COMES OFF BY
>> Mark: GOOD JOB
THE FIELD.
>> PERSONAL. CANNOT DO
IS GIVE THEM LIFE BY TURNING THE
IT FORCES THE REFEREES TO MAKE A
CALL, BECAUSE OF
>> Mike: POOLE, DRIVE AND
BOTH POOLE AND THOMPSON STARTING
TO KNOCK DOWN SOME SHOTS FOR
GOLDEN STATE,
HORFORD TO SMART.
THEM, RIGHT FROM THE START OF
THE GAME.ND
DEFLECTED OFF DRAYMOND GREEN. O.
YOU'VE GOT TO TRY TO TAKE AWAY
THAT SHOTES
OFF THE BENCH FOR PRITCH
>> Mike: THERE'S THE HUSTLE DOWN
HERE TO A DOUBLE BIG
LINEUP WITH HORFORD
>> Mark: I LIKE